[Music]
thanks guys for coming out tonight
time we will be continuing our coverage
of the semi slots this week the complete
sent me Slav part three I think were you
guys here for the other ones are you
here for okay awesome yes we've got some
people that have seen it some new faces
but no worries you can always jump in on
these series any time and tonight I
thought you know as a little reward here
maybe we will mostly focus on some games
I got three games to show
maybe we'll get through them all tonight
maybe we won't but the whole point of
this series is we're not going to rush
so we're going to go over three
different games in the Reynolds attack
also known as the Reynolds variation but
you know attack sounds better so this is
something that white can initiate and
we're going to go ahead and have a look
so we're going to go over to the board
now and this first game that we're going
to look at tonight is Anatoly Karpov
versus Viswanathan Anand and this was
played in the World Championship 1998 a
knockout are you like upset yeah so yeah
Bensimon has some serious opinions about
these knock-up knockout tournaments but
you'll have to ask them another time so
we're going to get to this game and so
one more time we're going through the
semi slob tonight this has always been
car Bob's preferred move order but he's
going to arrive at the position we've
been looking at and so here we have it
we have a Moran and black gets to take
and play an early b5 we've covered some
different Bishop retreats but we're
going to look at the main line tonight
also we've talked about a six here but
we're going to talk about the move
Bishop to b7 and last week we talked
about the moves efore and a3 in this
position but tonight our main focus is
going to be on the main line so when you
play the Moran this is what you're going
to face more often than not white
castles which okay obviously a very
sensible move and it follows sort of the
basic rule that we've been following
when you know black decides to play
Bishop b7 you should Castle if he had
started with the move
six than usually four is the right move
to play so this is where we are and now
black plays a six his next move is c5
this is you know the typical way of
playing when they play a 60 play e4 and
black plays c5 so we'll pause here for
just a second so far black has done
pretty well he's got reasonable squares
for his pieces you know he just needs to
get his Bishop out and he can castle he
has you know some attack on the center
so it has to be a little cautious but
the big plus for white in this position
is his lead in development so it's up to
white now to try to initiate some action
in the center and there's a couple
different ways to do it so I'm gonna I
guess we got a couple more people here
so we're gonna I'm gonna ask the class
what you guys would do here as white in
just a second how would you take
advantage of the fact that your castled
and you got your pieces out to decent
squares what would you guys play here is
white I'm just curious
yeah likable Denis maybe buy ya d5 this
is indeed the main move and this is the
Reynolds attack and this is what we're
going to be focusing on for much of our
lecture I do want to point out this move
e5 which i think is kind of tempting
because you're you know attacking the
knight and really the only reason i'm
going to show it is because i played a
blitz game last night that was my prep
so instead of actually looking at this
game I you know played some blitz and I
got this position and I had black in my
opponent did not play very well so if
you're black in this position obviously
Knight to d5 looks like a pretty
tempting move but a bit more critical is
taking on d4 so immediately breaking
down the center and here my opponent
didn't find basically the only move in
this position what you sort of have to
play in this position believe it or not
is Knight takes b5 so if he had played
this then he would probably it probably
would have led to an equal position
because here you can take
and that gives you time to move your
night out of the way you're going to
take on e5 so after his Knight moves you
take on e5 and when you know where its
Queen goes you can get a position like
this there's you know clearly at least
equal so this is no problem at all for
black so that's you know the best you
can do after this then you know probably
d5 and the Reynolds attack was a better
way to play my opponent however played a
very bad move he took on f6 looks
reasonable enough and often that's how
you play these types of positions but
not here I took on c3 and probably he
should just take back on c3 or play
Queen to e2 but you know he wanted to
continue his blunder in his path yeah so
now like I knew I was better but
computer gave like monster numbers here
already he went here super blunder let
me play a nice pretty move though now I
can take them b2 he took here which is
quadruple blunder and I took here and so
this happened that also was a mistake
that was a mistake and then obviously
Bishop takes f3 very good move
I'm kind of proud of the move I played
though Knight to e5 and here he resigned
because he's in a lot of trouble so that
should give you some ideas of how
quickly things can actually go wrong for
white and how fast blacks you know
initiative can can even get really
active to he gets active pieces as well
as white okay so going back to this
position here our focus today is going
to be on the main line which is the
moved d5 now one thing you might have
noticed is black can win upon however
this would be very dangerous you know
it's not time to open up the e-file
because your king stuck in the center
but if we went here let's just have a
little fun let's say he goes here we
should probably be kind of worried but
let's be extra greedy just for fun
I did I love my computer actually think
here forever so a four which is not the
most popular move might actually be a
you know one of the best moves here but
even the simple idea of taking here now
you can attack this piece by grabbing
this guy so in a position like this
things are looking pretty good for white
for example if you develop casually I
can play Bishop f4 the idea is if you
castle
Queen b7 and it's not going to be very
easy to defend your pawn and if you push
it then you're you're not gonna be able
to defend this thing so it you know so
it's you know obviously not advised that
you open the center in this position you
got to get your stuff out and castle and
the main move was played in this game so
this is Anand with black here Queen to
c7 hmm excuse me and it's kind of
important for black in these lines to
control the e5 square so this is very
sensible square for the Queen in black
over the next moves he's going to okay
so one thing is white is going to take
here on e6 and create nicely lated pawn
that he might be able to attack in the
future so blacks plan involves playing
the move c4 and after this Bishop moves
away now you have a square for your
knight
sometimes your Bishop but mostly your
knight that would be able to protect the
e6 pawn if necessary so that's a very
common theme in the game he took right
away sometimes
they wait but in the game he took right
away and he went to see to knowing that
black is going to play C 4 so a bit of
prophylaxis C 4 anyway and here this is
the main main position that we're going
to focus on here there's actually three
moves that I want to look at so we're
gonna look at three different games with
the three different moves the big theme
early on is attacking this week eeep on
so the most popular move is Knight to g5
Knight to d4 also very popular and also
what was played in the game which is
actually a rather dangerous system if
you don't know what you're what you're
doing here
Queen to e2 and you're just getting
ready you know you're trying to control
you v so maybe I'm going to push e5 and
on my next move I might move my knight
and try to attack the e6 pawn so black
played Bishop to d6 again we're still
fighting for a 5 and so again there's
two moves obvious in all these positions
usually this Knight can go one of two
different ways in the game he went to
the center 9 to d4 Knight to g5 is not
very scary in this position whenever
they attack our pawn usually Knight to
c5 is the move we're going to see a lot
tonight and if f4 we can play h6 and
okay there's there's more than one line
here but just to give you guys sort of
an idea
Knight to d3 and this is a very typical
sacrifice in this line so this is kind
of a move that you should be aware of in
all of these lines very often black
sacrifices his Knight so you know he's
going to stack up on and why it's going
to be able to win upon here but you do
get control of the light squares and you
know this is just a typical sacrifice
that usually gives you enough
compensation because your pieces are
very active usually to castle put a rock
on the D file and Black's doing okay so
this should be quite alright for him for
example after castling let's see
actually think this is a game I do want
to show this one game to that it was
it's a brief it's a pretty short game
Bure of sheer off hastings 1991 they
reach this position so notice that if
you after castling 'if i've right away
is not a threat because we can check and
then move our night away
but after king h1 now he is threatening
Matt okay and now a very strange
decision probably he should lay Queenie
- because there's a rook on the same
file as this Queen but he played Knight
to d4 and I'm not sure how he had
anticipated escaping this you know self
pin he pinned himself because now black
already has a very close to winning
position already just this paint is so
annoying
and so that's indeed this already led to
a great position for black here he went
after the dark squared bishop and this
is actually one of the most important
bishops for white so if you can get the
dark squared Bishop and this guy is
unimposing out really well in blacks
favor okay so even went back you got to
swap off the bishop now he takes
now after this night is still in a pin
he attacks it again we can keep
attacking it and okay and here we took
you can also take with the bishop which
might actually be a little bit stronger
okay and in this position he achieved
sort of a technical winning position
here so if you know you're 2700 you
should be able to win all these
positions like this
it's an openings class so I just wanted
to show the opening but uh we'll do that
because if we show the whole game then
Bensimon is morally obliged to you know
put it in the comments below well I
guess that was an interesting game and
just an idea of just how fast things can
blow up in White's face okay so instead
in this game Knight to d4 attacking the
pawn on e6 so black will defend
and now f4
white has a majority over on the
kingside so that's where he's going to
be pushing his pawns more often than not
Black has a majority over here so often
- in the endgame you know maybe if I can
start playing b4 and I can get my own
pawns rolling I have the potential to
make a passer but my priority is black
is the castle and be safe but for the
moment you've threatened 'if I've so I
can't let you play e5 so black plays e5
there's actually two very tempting moves
here
I think Knight f5 right just jump to a
very active square I think that's very
tempting and what about this move the
sacrifice well in the game he went in
for the sacrifice so we're going to come
back and we're going to look at this
which is Karpov so maybe you'd you know
you didn't guess that he would sacrifice
this is the first time this was played
so he actually had done some prep and
obviously it's a world championship so
he was a little bit prepared if instead
Knight to f5 it's not a big deal
I mean castle and if here does anybody
know what the move is here for black
it's it's an idea we we touched on just
briefly which one rook id8 yet you could
do this I'm tempted now just to take and
then we're going to take back and I'm
going to take here
yeah this is a bit of a problem yeah yes
you have to be careful there's actually
in these lines they are super sharp they
get really sharp very quickly so you do
have to be very very careful because
there's there's a lot going on here in
the center and so again it's a typical
motif in this line the correct move is
Knight to d3 again so this is sort of
the common idea of sacking upon and okay
you get a position like this that is I
mean roughly equal you are down upon but
you again have very active pieces an
unopposed like squared bishop that looks
pretty strong so this is something that
could occur so that Knight d3 that's the
move to keep in mind in a lot of these
lines however we are we're going to take
the more adventurous path and people
have sort of different views on this
move we're going to look at night D
takes b5 probably it's all been worked
out to a draw but it as you can imagine
this is very dangerous for black you
better know what you're doing because
I'm sacrificing and your king is still
in the center and white over the next
few moves is going to have to keep the
initiative going because if we can just
castle and be safe um well then you know
we're going to be looking pretty good
and also we're going to understand why
the move Queen e2 was played because now
sometimes I take your C pond and get
three pawns for the piece which is going
to end up happening in this line okay
and now after a relatively forcing
sequence here okay obviously we take
this one
dark-squared bishop is a very good piece
so we'll grab that guy check and how
would you guys play white here again we
got to keep the initiative every move
has to kind of have a threat likeable
Dennis rook d1 okay this is a forceful
move right you're attacking the Queen I
think your rook actually belongs here on
the F file though because you know
you're ready to open the file so now
I'll just move out of the way and now if
you take here it doesn't come with a
temple on my queen so I can have time to
do whatever I want to do yeah
tanked on c4 so this is actually a
problem Eva yeah you let a little tactic
happen to you the I you lined up your
your stuff and it's true that you do
have this check here and then I can just
go here though and you know we can do
this but it looks like I'm going to win
some stuff yeah so you can't actually
take right away that's that's the
problem in this position so the move is
to take on e5 and after you take back
again forcing moves
yeah it's either yeah Bishop f4 or rook
to f5 rook at five was played so I guess
if here one this is probably all right
but again if I get to like castle next
move then I'm doing fine not really sure
what your next if you have a lot more
force right yeah yeah the remove does
make sense and now you have to move your
queen
protect your knight and now he grabbed
this so three pawns for the piece and
the black king is still in the center
now I assume objectively this position
is equal because every chess position is
equal justice draw and this shouldn't be
any exception here though it is a bit
scary is black I think if you face this
in a real game you know you realize you
have to be rather exact Anand was up to
the task for for a while rook to c8 very
good move protects the night and you
know there might be some stuff going on
on the C file check
and you went with that night back so
he's hoping to trade the bishops so a
very interesting decision that's indeed
what happened here so far so good
now Bishop g5 and notice you're not able
to castle here because of Queen b3 check
so black still can't Castle black you
know he does have his his own activity
but you know it's kind of a kind of
double edged which is what you can
expect with this variation so instead
Queen d6
check and here comes the mistake if I'm
not mistaken he put King up 7 what he
should have done was Queen b8 and trade
the Queen's and it's still three pawns
for the piece but in general this should
favor the side with the pieces if you're
not getting checkmated the Queen's are
off the board it should be a little bit
better for the guy with the pieces you
play king f7 a very tricky move offering
the rook in the corner and black is
saying you know I have a bit of an
attack too so he went for this and does
black really have enough is your attack
strong enough obviously this this rook
is awesome I can get my Queen into the
action I have this check available
sometimes this night we'll be able to
come into the game some way are you a
little bit out of place over there well
he began with a check
and he took on e for threatening made on
g2 and the rook on f5 so he saved his
rook and blocked the Jeep on rook to f3
and perhaps this'll move that a black
head and counting on rook takes g2
what's this all about well now you've
walked into this pin Knight to e5 and
perhaps here
he had only considered the move rook a
to f1 seems like that might be something
the white would play but this actually
leads to a perpetual believe it or not
we can take and when you take back
there's quite a lot of ways to achieve
the perpetual but for example we could
do this a lot we could do that a lot and
there's other lines but it should lead
to a draw but here white had a surprise
a very shocking move so I'll I'll leave
it to you guys you can pause at home if
you want a little more time what did
Karpov come up with here
she said Queen takes g7 Wow
he takes g7 is that it yes it is and
showering exclams everywhere so he takes
and now we get to trade off lots of
stuff and now he takes here and again we
reached a rather technical position this
is the kind of position Karpov really
good at now this game is 108 moves and
we're only on move 33 so we're going to
just say that this is enough this is a
winning position and we're going to go
on to the next game here well we'll
admire the technique and this is what
we're going to see a lot of today these
games where it gets very tactical very
quickly and then it leads to a
technically winning position which is
also why I said in the intro to this
series it has everything that's good
about chess it requires lots of opening
knowledge and it requires lots of
tactical ability as well as strategic
understanding and the ability to win you
know positions like this so it's really
good for training your chests and all
sorts of different areas that you might
need to improve which is why I really
like the semi Slav it's it's everything
that's good about chess all in one
opening all right and now now he's
pushing these guys he has to make sure
his King stays safe lots of checks
no he's getting close here all right
and so here's where the game ended
because now blacks getting mated all
right so a very strong example here of
just how powerful that sacrifice really
was on b5 so you do have to be worried
and okay if I could just you know trade
it off the Queen's and you know just
played the pieces against the three
pawns then the game might have had a
completely different outcome but it was
a very well played game for white which
is why I and I thought I was only fair
will show one game from White's
perspective so our next game of the day
this is the game between Rustom Kazon
Deneuve versus Gary Kasparov it was
played in Linares 2005 okay and Gary
played the semi Slav a few times in his
life so he'll be a good example for us
again we're looking at castling today
alright I played a 60 played e4 c5 and
the Reynolds attack here we have moved
e5 okay so again Queen to c7
controlling e5 is essential in the
beginning here he took right away and
went back and so we've achieved this
position yet again and we looked at the
move Queen to e2 which is actually very
dangerous with the Queen on e2 looking
at the C pawn which doesn't look like
anything actually can lead to some
sacrifices that you know like should at
least be a little bit prepared for but
now we're going to focus on the move
Knight to d4 and this originally was the
main line in this system it's sort of
fallen you know out of popularity but a
move that you really must know if you
can't play like this how natural is that
you move to the center and you attacked
my pond
so again we're going to defend it that's
why he played the move c4 so we can play
Knight to c5 and now if again you play
Queen to e2 you can lead right back into
this position where you can take on b5
or you can go
f-five so white still has a chance to
transpose back into that last game but
here he played an independent train okay
Bishop e3 a sensible developing move and
in a lot of lines imagine this night re
maneuvers itself maybe I'm thinking of
trading for your guy and then winning
your e6000 that's actually a theme that
might occur in this type of position
here Gary play d5 a tempting move but
not a very good one is castling
queenside it looks good there's a pin on
the D file and now you're going to play
e5
however after Queen e2 we're again
thinking about some sacrifices on b5 and
this can get kind of scary for example
'if I've I take so I got two ponds and
okay you can defend your C pawn but I
mean it looks kind of scary white is
really opening you up a lot faster and
you have no attack going on so this
could be pretty dangerous for black so
castling is in a lot of these lines you
do Castle but especially when the nights
over here on g5 because there's less
sacking on b5 going on but instead he
played a 5 here and he went Knight to f3
he's going to ream Anu over to g5 where
he's going to be you know looking at
this square maybe I can trade for your
knight and then I can drop my knight in
to e6 again obviously tempting is Knight
to f5 but if you play here we can sort
of play around the knight you can
imagine a position like this Queen f3
the Queen it mostly lines where the
Queen comes out to f3 she's going to h3
so a position like this could occur and
you could either play Knight to d4 or
Queen to d7 and you'll just kind of have
to play around this night he's not doing
so so much and you're going to probably
cancel on the Queen side if allowed so
okay if that's what white wants to do
it's not actually that big of a nuisance
as it might might seem at first you can
sort of play around that guy which is
why instead he decided to go to f3 again
he's going to g5 this would be to a
sensible developing move Knight g5 and
now black played a very good move
so one of points ideas is I'm going to
take this and I'm going to be able to
plant my knight on e6
and Gary just cancelled which is an
exchange sacrifice this white took the
night and play 96
and after Queen b6 he won in exchange
and this actually is it should actually
be really good for black again when you
have an unopposed dark squared bishop
this usually ends up being very strong
for black that's the kind of imbalance
that actually can favor you as black
there's a lot of pressure now on F to my
bishop Queen rook my knight maybe can
sometimes jump into g4 I have lots of
pressure on f2 so I definitely have
enough compensation here for the
exchange and let's see how the game
continued in the game Knight to d5 was
played we'll come back to this Queen e2
is the more popular move in among other
moves let's just give you a sample
continuation we can start pushing on
that side in here that's also a nice
move you can interpose this and in this
there's actually in this particular line
there's lots of drawing methods I'm just
going to demonstrate one here's the most
common way to draw but there's a lot of
lines that are just known to be forced
draws in this particular variation with
Queen e2 here we won't go too much into
it but in the game we're just going to
focus on what was played Knight to d5
which is actually a mistake and I do
want to give the audience here a good
chance to see if you can play like Gary
I think this is a very tall order in
this case it's a try to think of a
couple move sequence here there's some
some tactics in this position and we'll
we'll see if you guys can find to me
again you can pause at home all right
Steven looks like you have an ID on your
head
take the bishop on you take a look by
the item v5 Commission okay very parting
with a very nice bishop what's what's
the idea being a one stopping the attack
on the Queen stopping the attack of the
Queen yeah uh-huh yeah if you figured it
out I want to play Knight g4 next day
okay so you want to play Knight g4 which
looks like it hangs a knight but but oh
there's more yeah okay you want to take
this way
oops huh yeah you did gift me a knight
there that was rather generous you're
probably a mistake we're getting close
though know this we're on the start of
the right track and if you came up with
this at home
congratulations you found the second
best move but let's look at one idea
here an example would be this is sort of
a move we're trying to make we're trying
to make Bishop takes f2 you're on the
right track we're trying to make this
work and if here now we can play this
move that you were thinking of with the
idea that if they take well now Knight
to g4
and this just totally wins because I'm
going to take your rook and if you take
here you you might get checkmated let's
let's go all the way to checkmate
so that's
sort of in the position but let's
actually do this one run through this
one more time after here I don't have to
take your Bishop if I understand the
tactics here I can just play like Queen
to f3 maybe my next move I'm just gonna
bring all my pieces in so you obviously
can just save this guy wherever you want
to go and this actually should be fine
um so we're sorry after 90 d5 we're
really close to the idea now really
close so see if we can put it all
together and come up with a combination
okay it looks like looks like maybe
you've come up with that dentists yeah
might be vision safety or mr. takes d5
yeah uh-huh yeah now you're talking
right and in the game he had to move
over so again if here we have the same
situation where 9 to g4 very powerful
and strong the rook is pinned and we're
going to win some material alright so in
the game seeing this he played King 2h
one inning now he has a simple but very
strong plan E for the next move III III
he's getting his passer a little bit
closer whereas white didn't push her
it's his passer now so white now wants
to push his guy so he blockaded and
after a four black made a very strong
move showing an understanding of the
position well white might want to do
instead of playing a four is to bring
his bishop to the e6 square that'd be a
really good square for that Bishop so
Gary played g6 he's not going to let
that happen
and
this position is not good at all but he
played after taking g3 which is a very
bad move and Gary was quick to punish
him because now after Knight to h5
everything is going to sacrifice itself
on g3 so he played Queen to g4 okay that
protects g3 a little bit but now there
is a sacrifice on g3 that works which
Bishop takes excellent you know so if
you don't take then I just robbed you of
a pond so he took and I'm Knight takes
check and in the game he went to g2 King
g1 is probably the lesser evil but now
after E - this is you know unpleasant if
you just go here this is actually quite
strong for black you're you're not going
to like what's going to come next but
what you can do is you can get rid of
these guys we can trade a little bit and
then I get to take care it made a queen
you can also make a rook I don't know
which whichever you like you get some
position like this that guy should be
really good and it's winning for black
okay so you probably saw that and you
said okay I'll go here instead now the
game is very close to over this lets the
rook into f2 and my Knights attacked he
just moved his knight also now we have
some threats going on right here so
white stopped that and obviously you can
take the bishop on c2 but you know chess
artist that he is he played the very
cool move
h5 there's not a whole lot of options
for that Queen it's just not really
going very far
so it had to take on g6 and bring a rip
to the G file and all right and then
white resigned here and again it's a
technical task for these guys to win
this position but you know stuff that's
going on right here that you might not
like
so yeah this see if we have time for the
next normal phone room and now we're
going to look at the main main line and
we're going to follow the game pretty
drag nickel ik versus Alexi shear off
from Horkan 1994 okay we had a big
discussion of where the city actually is
and still nobody knows comment below
where's the city you know use Google we
never thought of using Google okay so
here we are we're going to get to our
main line efore d5 Reynolds attack
okay so they delayed taking on e6 for
just a moment and we come now to our
main course in this position Knight to
g5 so this will conclude it for the
Moran after this game I think what we're
gonna move on some some anti Moran's and
part four but this is it when you play
them around this is the main main line
Knight to g5 okay you attacked my pawn
so i protect it and there's actually two
moves really be 5 is the most trodden
path this is probably still the main
line sacrificing a pawn
so that you can play rook e1 and stuff
can happen here very interesting though
is this move Queen f3 I think it's a
very interesting idea and the idea is to
put more pressure on the e6 pawn by
playing Queen h3 and the main move is
Bishop d6 I'm going to come right back I
think I don't think this is particularly
the strongest move this hasn't been
played very often this is kind of a an
interesting idea that doesn't get played
as much as it possibly could so here's
sort of the main line in well this
should be good I mean optically it looks
pretty good for white because he's you
know breaking through a little bit on
the Queen side this this should be
decent for black however I want to show
I'm sorry we'll go back to this after
Queen to f3 I want to show this move h6
and there's a little game here that I
want to show the game gross lane 2008
this was a correspondence game and 2008
so they are probably using computers and
every move here computer perfect and the
result was black wins
so these corresponding teams can
actually show you quite a lot because
here they are running their engines for
hours and hours and hours and it spits
out whatever and so you'd expect most
games to be a draw
but quite like this move h6 and if white
continues with this main idea you're
going to like this game it's a it's a
little less human than the other ones
but it's it's very it's very pleasing
castles rookie one now I'm going to play
e5 but I'm not going to sack upon and
get ready took the night so he's
sacrificing in exchange he's opening up
some files after the Queen takes okay
you got that but you know your little
little trap down there you're not
necessarily as cozy as you would like to
be and now before
okay
b5
now this is hanging this is hanging
and he ignores everything now that
everything's hanging I'm gonna keep
let's keep track of how many things are
hanging in this game just out of
interest here I'll get a clean one back
protects the Queen so still all the
nights are getting attacked Queen goes
over now you might think I'm going to
move my knight where I'm going to take
your knight
no I want to play this typical motif now
okay so what am I am I going to move my
stuff am I going to take you tonight
no attack your queen I'm gonna take your
queen so everything el queens are
hanging and Knights are still hanging
the rook is hanging which is it's fun to
use some some pretty colors here so
everything's hanging which is why I said
this is not necessarily the most human
game after here your attacks my rook
alright fine I'll take your knight
now you might expect me to take the rook
or take the pawn back I'll take the pawn
now you might think I'm going to move my
rook now I'm going to attack f2 we got
this position and somewhere around here
the computer starts to say yeah things
are looking favorable for black because
here yes the second exchange and he
comes back over here wins this and now
again this is sort of a technically
winning endgame though here is you know
computer super tactical melee but again
it's resulted in a position where white
is I assume his engine just told me
you're losing because that King is so
active but the material is the same it's
just the activity of the King so ok that
game was fantastic so I thought I would
have to show you guys and we'll come
back to our main featured game here yet
again so we got sheer off here with the
black pieces in his opponent played a 5
so again this is the most popular move
so you can expect to see this the most
and there's nothing better than to take
it
rookie one so yeah it looks a little bit
scary for black because you still have
to prove that you can castle
so black one to d6 and there's probably
nothing better than trading Queens here
for example if you play Queen - II - I
think I can just go here and if you want
to trade stuff this is actually totally
fine for black now so it's not too scary
so instead after Queen d6 we got the
trade of Queens and it should be three
so again we have the idea that I might
take your knight and then take on these
six and you castled
now before just grabbing this guy and
then chomping on e6 he got this free
developing move in all right now he took
it and he took here and all of this have
been played before so probably both
these players knew this they are both
pretty good at knowing some theory and
okay a move you can consider is taking
the bishop so that's very respectable
move the white tried which is this is
actually white played pivot the main
move which might be a surprise if you're
new to this type of position and still
this is all Theory where I move 21 this
is still all theory several games and
like hundreds of games in this position
still white has an idea of dislodging
this night this night is really
preventing white from doing what he
might want to do he wants to infiltrate
on the seventh rank so he's got to go
give her to this guy and so in the game
he played h3 the idea is g4 g5 and now
black showed a very deep understanding
of the position but again it's still all
theory
sometimes if this Knight isn't here so
let's you know let's just let's go do
some some nonsense and that's not that's
not nonsense enough I don't know where I
can put it to make my point work but
sometimes let's say we dislodge this
Knight
we're thinking of taking on g7 and then
you know coming down here attacking the
King attacking the bishop simply drew K
to b8 so he's already defending against
these tactical ideas and after g4 also
the works going to be eight because
you're going to play over here on this
side of the board Yulin here still all
theory I'm not actually sure where they
deviated somewhere around here they they
start to deviate so let's go ahead and
just sort of enjoy this this game on the
bishop bishop retreated
here I think here too you can actually
take here for Rookie 7 but this is what
happened
all right h6 what's going on here
aha
yes you can see how it just complicated
these positions really can get and over
kind of rushing but uh we don't have
that much time okay
night before a very good move
let me grab this one
nine to c6
so white is very active pieces you know
knees you know the king is a little bit
boxed in but we do have this big passer
here so I believe this is the start of
his downfall so now we go here we place
here
see to it in close
now here I think white thought he had a
little trick and you played rook f4 so I
thinks he has this little trick but
again I'll let you guys figure this out
this will be the last this will have to
be the last one a very tricky move a
very very tricky move there's a small
threat yes right so that's sort of his
idea yeah check check is the idea
there
yeah and if the bishop takes yeah
there's some back rank stuff
so if you took here and okay maybe white
already thought he was lost or maybe he
was banking it all on this move and now
your choices are limited you can get
mated one or block with your rope so he
blocked with this rook there's lots of
ways to capture he went here and we're
going to see in this position so he's
going to check and then the King's gonna
be forced up and so both sides are
queening he went back to block that
check text the knight Queens now he
takes and gets to check and white makes
a queen but just simply after taking
here white resigned and so again a
tactical sequence followed by another
technically winning endgame now if we
had time we could play this out but uh
suffice to say it actually is a clear
win for black in this position mess
around with it if you want on your own
but uh that'll have to do it for the
Moran so that I'll conclude it for that
next week we will do the anti Moran's
which are some very interesting ways
that if white thinks you know he's going
to avoid some of these lines we saw how
complicated and sharp they can be we'll
see what happens if you know he doesn't
he's not willing to go into these lines
but he still wants to play the e3
variation that we have seen so again as
always go ahead hit a like share
subscribe and thanks to everybody for
coming out tonight
[Music]
Oh
[Music]